on deep web message boards and social
media many conspiracy theorists
are expressing dismay and disappointment
following president joe biden's
inauguration
last month it's just belief that that
somehow trump was going to
come out victorious and that there would
be all these um
kind of democratic figures sort of put
on trial
adherents of the conspiracy theory q
anon some of whom were involved in the
riot at the u.s
capitol on january 6th believe leading
democratic politicians are part of a
global cabal of pedophilic cannibals
some of them have now rejected that
bizarre belief system but
some are gravitating to more militant
groups
so the big wild card that i think we're
looking at in the united states
is not whether we have an insurgency
but how fast and how hot it will run
i will say that the rhetoric among fine
right extremists is hot i don't think
it's ever been
hotter than it's been as long as i've
been covering it
racism anti-semitism and hatred of
so-called
elites have deep roots in american
society and culture
scholars say that's not going to
disappear the hardest
edges of that movement are going to be
around we have an insurgency
and the issue is who's going to lead
this insurgency
what are the leaders and ideological
pinnings
of this insurgency going to be because
it's around
grievance the republican party that
enabled trump for years has seen an
influx of hardcore conspiracy theorists
for example
newly elected republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene is a firm
believer in the q anon
fantasy so many americans are blind
and when they hear these stories about
pedophiles and they hear these stories
about satanic worship
they don't want to believe it's true
they just don't another possibility
far right and conspiracy groups may
split with republicans and form their
own party
and if we see some kind of breakaway
political party
or some kind of charismatic telegenic or
other type of leader
that will supercharge the risk what
seems almost
certain is that the threat of right-wing
political violence whether
perpetrated by so-called lone wolves
targeting minorities
or more organized plots against the
government and its officials
will be a feature of the american
political landscape
for some time to come rob reynolds al
jazeera
los angeles